alexey navalny's wife julia
arrives in court the first time she'll
have seen her husband since he called
off his three-week hunger strike
beamed in via video link from jail
navalny was obviously thinner he'd lost
three and a half stone his lawyer said
but he was as defiant as ever and full
of love for his wife
[Music]
[Music]
on a diet of five spoons of porridge
today he's slowly easing off his hunger
strike
his lawyers giving a little more detail
not surprisingly his appeal to overturn
a guilty verdict for supposedly
slandering a world war ii veteran did
not go his way
the crackdown against alexei navalny
just continues to
intensify in a separate hearing his
lawyers said that they'd found
in the case files that another criminal
case had been launched against him
and two of his key allies back in
february under some
obscure article of russian law normally
reserved for neo-nazis or religious
cults
proceedings are underway to label
navalny's anti-corruption foundation
extremist too making it impossible his
team says
to continue operating in russia
this graffiti in st petersburg calling
navalny a hero
of our times had a short-lived shelf
life
after this quick repaint someone else
wrote putin is a thief
exactly what navalny has always called
him
donna magna sky news moscow